ils seront donc sept en tout une femme
et six hommes vous les découvrez ici par
ordre alphabétique
hervé mariton a été recalé n'a pas
rassemblé les 250 et luttons vingt
parlementaires quoi ça y est je suis
candidat de la primaire de la droite et
du centre
j'étais en train de réfléchir à tout ça
je suis en train de vous écrire un mail
puis votre fini je vais plutôt vous le
dire directement à la moment où vous
devenez français vos ancêtres
ce sont les gaulois et c'est
vercingétorix mon père et hongrois on
n'a pas appris l'histoire la hongrie car
quand on coupe les racines d'un arbre il
meurt on n'est pas tous pareils il faut
respecter notre diversité
c'est donc à 6h34 qu'alain juppé décide
d'envoyer ce tweet très lapidaire
nullité du débat politique que soulève
certains à droite et à gauche on débat
des gaulois et si on parlait d'avenir
pour moi faire campagne c'est pas lâcher
une incongruité tous les jours pour
faire parler de soi après vous lâcher je
cite une incongruité par jour je ne
polémiquerai pas ni avec juppé ni qui
que ce soit dire les autres sont nuls
c'est classique jusque des à part dont
c'est ce que dit tout le monde écoute et
attendant le prochain jeu sera tellement
voir si j'arrive à 3 millions de plus
j'aurai des gens de samples j'aurai des
déçus du hollandisme
rien je convaincu tu verras je crois tu
paris j'ai gagné la primaire un coq à
parier que la mairie n'est pas moderne
contrairement à ce qu'essaient de faire
croire façon assez
classique est superficiel de l'or des
choses je ne cherche pas la bénédiction
du petit paris mondain
je cherche la résurrection du peuple de
france voilà la différence entre eux et
nous je n'avais pas vraiment répondu à
la question qui vous étaient posées
cette fois je vous répondrai à la
prochaine fois vous prendrez votre
minutes pour le club à tout à l'heure
j'avais quelque chose à dire avant lors
j'ai dit voilà je veux dire à tous les
manifestations que le 20 novembre le
poisson est à 2 euros
on en profite je ne serai pas de martine
aubry de droite c'est à dire qu'on a eu
une obsédée des 35 heures on va pas être
une obsédée obsédés des 39 heures il ya
des déçus du hollandisme qui parfois
aller voter pour nicolas sarkozy
précédemment est ainsi aujourd'hui
veulent venir vers nous ils sont les
bienvenus par combien coûte un taux
chocolat jean françois copé fait ça
dépend détails je pense que ça doit être
un loto de 10 ou 15 centimes d'euros
pour 100 g de chouquettes je l'aimais
off aller j'émettrais au-delà de 1 1
euro en dessous de 2 et au delà d'eux en
dessous de 2 c difficile à trouver
vous avez fait perdre l'élection de 2012
françois d'ailleurs je suis un citoyen
j'ai le droit de voter pour qui je veux
corinne rire ou que je connais bien ils
étaient quatre fois candidat à la
présidentielle le prix jamais fait les
choses les dirigeants l'udf non ça on
peut pas dire qu'on ait fait des choses
ensemble il a été ministre est question
nationale aérien touché en cinq ans et
portant des femmes quand j'ai un boulot
énorme oui entre autres qui me plaisait
quand j'ai acheté des chouquettes chemin
de l'école c'était la boulangère c'est
la fin d'une histoire l'émoi dans la
jupe et
pour les copines on voit un peu rigoler
vous soutenez alain juppé j'entends
enfin ça vous a pas échappé qui est
attaqué par les sarkozystes en raison du
soutien de françois bayrou
nous refusons le centre girouette qui
est avec nous lundi pour gagner la ville
de pau et qui est le mardi avec françois
hollande pour concourir au tour du
socialisme la tête du pays
rien sondage à paraître demain sondage
ifop très sérieux pour psychologies
magazine sur la gentillesse la question
c'est quel candidat est le plus gentil
et la réponse c'est vous est ce que vous
vous en bouche un coin
le community manager du compte de
campagne de nicolas sarkozy il est allé
de son petit message il n'a pas hésité à
faire le parallèle entre cette affiche
et un faire part de décès depuis là et
l'a retiré son son tweet c'est quand
même plus polis est-ce que vous avez un
mot gentil pour nicolas sarkozy qui est
le dernier de ce classement
certains sur son plateau avait fait
aussi la promesse ne jamais se
représenter si jamais été battus ou de
se consacrer entièrement leur ville donc
s'ils avaient tenu leur propre pour
serait peut-être moins nombreux sur ce
plateau
si j'écoute bruno si à chaque fois qu'on
est battu on n'a plus le droit de se
présenter je te rappelles tu as été
battu à la présidence de l'ump par
commence d'abord par essayer d'être élu
tu verras que c'est très difficile
ensuite je vais vous dire une chose
sicile nicolas lozzi amplement que
jacques chirac et je vais vous
mitterrand n'ont pas été battus comme
président sortant ont été battus comme
candidat je ne regrette pas ta
nomination
non je ne suis pas sûr de le refaire
mais je ne regrette pas pris parfois
j'étais envie de tout envoyer bouler et
quand on me dit là pour la 25e fois à
est ce que vous allez fendre l'armure
vous faites chier avec votre armure 1
parce qu'il ya longtemps qu'elle est
fendu dans tous les sens l'armure
le duo annoncé par les médias et par les
va la réalité donc
lui aussi a fait salle comble au zénith
de paris hier soir alain juppé est en
pleine forme j'ai la pêche avec vous ces
personnes dernier débat
dans quel état d'esprit vous l'abordez
monsieur je vais déroger à une des
règles que je me suis dit que c'est
jusqu'ici dans mes relations avec la
presse je ne vais pas répondre à vos
questions
et pourquoi vous êtes en train de nous
couper la parole sur des sujets
absolument fondamentaux pour vous
laisser de la liberté
mais justement on n'en veut pas on n'est
pas des commentateurs on n'est pas là
pour s'interpeller les uns entre les
autres puisque visiblement vous n'avez
pas l'intention d'écouter ce que j'aime
bien c'est vous qui avez dit que vous je
quitterais de la peau messieurs je vous
remercie de votre habitat vers sigean
fédérons bistrot merci c'est ce qu'on
appelle faire du base à pas cher il
serait bon aussi que chez nous à droite
au centre
on sera capable de montrer qu' il ya des
idées nouvelles il ya des visages
nouveaux on est capable de changer pour
que cela fonctionne pas alors avec vous
il ya quelques il vous dis-je repérer de
cabaye qu'est ce qui vous dit que ça ne
va pas fonctionner à rusal de gaulle
avait été interrogé sur ce concept de
primaire
il avait même été très cruel il avait
dit la primaire ça consiste en réalité à
choisir en gros le plus inodore incolore
et sans saveur
premier des trois favoris à voter
françois fillon dans la frénésie
médiatique
les bordelais le soir le zambien est
grande
des patients ont fait la queue il fait
beau lui ne va pas faire la queue
l'ancien chef de l'état se présentent
directement devant les assesseurs
maintenant aujourd'hui en anticipant ses
filles on se retrouve face à alain juppé
pourquoi ce que personne n'imagine ce
scénario sont les chiffres officiels de
la haute autorité de cette primaire
françois fillon est donc le grand
gagnant du soir 44,1 pour cent
nicolas sarkozy a été la cible de tout
le monde en russie l'avait cette
spécificité d'avoir été ancien président
a révélé j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour
alain juppé mais les choix politiques de
françois fillon mme sont plus proches
[Applaudissements]
j'ai décidé de continuer le combat
j'ai une pensée particulière pour
nicolas sarkozy qui a été le président
de la la droite a donné une bonne image
j'étais heureux de participer à ce
combat
fillon 54 40
encore sa présence
je n'arrive pas
c'est un événement invraisemblable ça et
pour ma part extrêmement joyeux très
prometteur mais totalement imprévisible
dans cette proportion
à
les filles ont apporté à une famille
traditionaliste
je suis plus ouvert au modernisme je me
sens plus proche du pap françois que de
sens commun ou de la manif pour tout ce
que j'entendais tout à l'heure alain
juppé préférez le pape françois à la
manif pour tous je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
est totalement écouté et lu lé pa
françois parce que sur la plupart des
sujets sur lesquels alain juppé semble
vouloir me contester ne pas me françois
dit la même chose que moi car le
programme est trop dure il n'est pas
réaliste et il provoquera des blocages
dans la société conserve un vous dites
par françois fillon en margaret thatcher
icône ultra libérale elle est cocasse
d'excellentes
ça fait drôle d'abord j'aimerais bien
que françois fillon clarifie sa position
par exemple sur l'avortement
l'interruption volontaire de retraite de
grossesse il a commencé par lire dans
son livre que c'était un droit
fondamental des femmes
et puis il est revenu sur cette
déclaration jamais je n'aurais pu penser
que mon ami alain juppé tombe aussi beau
mais ça fait trente ans que je suis
parlementaire est ce qu'une seule fois
j'ai pris une position contre
l'avortement
une seule fois car je n'ai attaqué
jamais personne en dessous de la
ceinture comme je les ai entendus dire
j'ai simplement poser des questions sur
des clarifications qui me paraissait
nécessaire et j'aurai d'autres reposer
sur d'autres sujets c'est encore une
attaque inutile politicienne qui n'a pas
de sens mais vous a prévenu dès le
dimanche on les lit je continuerai le
combat
effectivement la tension est montée hier
françois fillon a répondu alain juppé
sur un ton un peu un peu sec et donc
voilà il ya une petite escarmouche dans
la journée de bière non non non il faut
pas voir l'épiderme trop sensible et
jouer les chochottes
pendant toute la campagne du premier
tour j'étais accusé d'être trop bout bah
je dis aujourd'hui que fillon est trop
dur voilà ce match nul au parc depuis
des mois et des mois je suis l'objet
d'une campagne absolument ignominieuse
qui a commencé par mme accusé d'avoir
financé sur fonds publics a bordeaux une
gigantesque mosquée qui n'existe pas
ensuite j'ai été rebaptisé si je peux
utiliser ce mot d'aller juppé grand bus
quitte bordeaux il faudrait pas que la
dernière semaine on redevienne la droite
la plus bête du monde et la dernière
campagne c'est tout simplement une
accusation de salafisme et de
antisémitisme ou sous-entendre l'asn et
ses proches
absolument pas libérez-moi terminée
absolument pas laissez-moi terminer
cette campagne me fais beaucoup de
balles on voit très bien qu'il est en
colère parce qu'au fond pendant des mois
et des mois
il n'a pas réagi aux attaques très
violentes de sarkozy et de son clan qui
finalement ils ont fait beaucoup de mal
histoire de dali juppé le sahara fils tu
pars quand je me fais traiter d'
homophobes tous les matins je n'ai pas
entendu non plus prendre la parole pour
assurer ma défense voilà chacun est
grand et s'occupe de ses affaires
ce soir alain juppé était sans doute un
petit peu en deçà de la main comme s'il
avait commencé peut-être à intégrer
l'idée sa défaite
ils sont plus de dix mille bureaux de
vote ouvrent leurs portes à 8h les
électeurs devront donc départager
françois fillon désormais favori et
alain juppé détendu au point de presque
oublié sa cotisation de 2 euros françois
fillon et alain juppé qui ont voté à la
même heure quasiment simultanément dans
les bureaux de vote différents
évidemment j'espérais une forte
mobilisation parce que j'espère tout
défendu l'idée jusqu'au bout et ça va
marcher
je suis sûr qu attend le verdict des
électeurs voilà maintenant vous êtes
confiant c'est eux qui parlent sur 2121
bureaux dépouillés et bien les scores
respectifs étaient pour françois frion
de 69 5% des voix et pour alain juppé de
30,5 pour cent des voir les écarte bouge
assez peu puisque françois fillon est
crédité de 68 5% tout à l'heure c'était
69,5 donc qui baisse de 1 point
comme je vis était engagé j'apporte dès
ce soir mon soutien à françois fillon je
lui souhaite bonne chance pour sa
prochaine campagne présidentielle
alain est un homme d'état et il le reste
est d'ailleurs françois fillon l'a
évoqué ce soir il a parlé de plus de
justice et de solidarité voici la
poignée de main j'aurais juste ajouter
une dernière chose ce n'est pas alain
juppé qui m'a blessé
ce sont les photographes il ya quelques
instants sur la page est tournée pour
moi
[Musique]